you
we're inspired by the passionate group
of racers playing in Forza and there is
no track in the world the players are
more passionate about than the
Nurburgring this is one of the true
icons of global motorsport and it's
making its next-gen debut in 425 you
know it turn 10 we live and breathe cars
we've got drifters tuners collectors car
nuts of every sort I've had the
opportunity to drive the real
Nurburgring and I can tell you it is
absolutely as awe-inspiring and as
intimidating as you heard
every bump every guardrail every surface
change it's all there this version of
the ring is the most ambitious piece of
content we've ever built it took 30
artists around the world working over
13,000 hours to recreate the ring from
the ground up for the next generation
reports of motorsport 5 we laser scanned
our tracks using brand-new
state-of-the-art technology as a result
we have the most complete picture of the
rain ever captioning
lighten atmosphere are important focuses
in forts of 5 while building the ring we
wanted to maximize the lighting for
impact shadows draping across the track
light rays punching through the trees
they all add a great sense of speed on
the course
we're including the full 16 mile
combined circuit something we've never
done it before it's a series before it's
fully integrated in multiplayer and into
the career the track really comes to
life and fortifies physics engine and
the detail is staggering this is a true
test of manna machine and it's available
right now for free